hi I'm Tessa Rhodes and I'm a designer
on IBM cloud and today we're going to
talk about platform as a service it's
hard to define platform as a service
without talking about its neighbors
infrastructure as a service or I as and
suffer as a service or cess let's start
with the foundation here with ayahs
ayahs is a set of compute networking and
storage resources that have been
virtualized by a vendor so that a user
can access and configure them any way
they want and design we have a concept
of talking about users called personas
and the persona for iies is a system
admin or an IT admin let's jump up to
the top with software as a service
that's the easy one software as a
service is just software that you don't
have to install on your machine and you
don't have to manually update and so the
user or software as a service could be
anyone in fact if you're watching this
on youtube right now the newer user of
software as a service it's usually
charged on a subscription model rather
than a one-time license fee then that
brings us to platform as a service past
takes advantage of all the virtualized
resources from Aya's and then just
obstructs them away so the user doesn't
have to worry about managing any of
those virtualized resources the user for
paas is not a system admin usually it's
usually a dev an IBM we call this dev
Jane that's the name of our persona and
so this whole metaphor the pyramid
metaphor is meant to indicate that as
you move down you're increasing
complexity in terms of your knowledge
and and management of infrastructure
resources and you're increasing the ease
of use another metaphor I use when I'm
talking to the designers on my team
about PA's is having to do with a car so
and this metaphor I as is like leasing a
car so if you've got released a car you
probably did a lot of research and you
care about the specs of the car and
their performance you care about the
color of the car what
a card is you're the one driving and
you're paying for it you're also paying
for the gas and any tolls or maintenance
with platform-as-a-service
in this metaphor that's more like
renting a car so say you're on vacation
and you just got off the air Airport and
you're going to pick up your rental car
you don't really care what color it is
uh you don't really even care about the
specs of it but you're still driving and
you're paying for the gas and any tolls
you go through suffers the service is
again the easiest one that one's more
like getting a taxi all right uber so if
the taxi aren't uber you don't care at
all about what kind of car it is what
color it is and in fact you're not even
the one driving or paying for gas or any
tolls because that's baked into the
price so let's think about what that
means in terms of cloud computing and
what the vendor provides and what the
developer or Jayne provides so the
winner provides servers storage
networking virtualization middleware the
operating system in the runtime
all that leaves for the developer to
provide is their data and applications
so this is and this is the vendor cloud
vendor so there are some pros and cons
with that just like with leasing renting
or getting a taxi the pros for using
platform-as-a-service are it's generally
assumed that it's quite fast and easy to
get an app up and running which is great
it's easy to create and delete the
resources which is important for say
you're running a proof-of-concept
app for a conference and you want to
spin it up right before the conference
and then delete it right after you're
not paying for the whole month and it's
easy to spin it up and delete it also
the cost so that results in some cost
benefit
another cost benefit of
platform-as-a-service is that you don't
have to pay for a full time system or IT
admin to run this app they can focus on
something else and another Pro is that a
lot of providers of
platform-as-a-service have been building
out some tools on their platform so you
can use DevOps tools collaboration tools
and there's a lot of API marketplaces
that have been coming out which is great
because you can just take those services
and plug them into your app again still
without having to worry about any of
this there are some cons too you think
platform-as-a-service
this big one is lack of control but some
people will still say that that is a pro
because although some people like to
pull all the levers and push all the
buttons having to do with fine-tuning
their infrastructure a lot of people
don't want to have to worry about that
nor do they have the understanding or
ability to do that another con is the
vendor lock-in it's a little bit hard to
migrate your app unless you're using an
open-source framework like Cloud Foundry
it's a little hard to migrate
platform-as-a-service app from one cloud
to another so make sure you trust and
like your cloud provider before you
choose it and then finally the
performance at scale can be an issue
performance at scale so say Jane the
developer had a platform as-a-service
proof-of-concept app from that
conference and then she released it to
10,000 people the next day it definitely
won't have the same in and out
performance as if it was running on a
dedicated bare metal server for example
so that's a consideration to have so I
hope that helps you understand the
benefits and the reasons for choosing
platform as a service thanks for
watching
if you have questions please drop us a
line below if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe and don't forget you
can always get started on cloud at no
cost by signing up for a free IBM cloud
account